why do you think audiences love stories
about lost wayward souls or maybe that's
just myself I mean yeah like linis
played venice in bass ackwards and again
and a similar character and also is it
rhett and puffy chair yeah so these
similar these sort of lost souls that
maybe we all sort of identify with in
some way what do you think it is that we
want to root for these people but at the
same time we condemn them in society ya
know it's interesting I don't know why
people love lost souls I think probably
because we're all lost souls and we're
all searching for things that we fund we
don't know where to find these things
and you know we're trying to return to
two places that we've lost in the past
or trying to find things that we think
are out there maybe they aren't but I I
personally I feel lost all the time so
that's why I connect to it at least when
J pitch to the idea for the story how
long before he actually cut this great
video together and put up the
Kickstarter campaign it was a while back
when he pitched it to me was probably a
year and a half ago and he worked on the
script for a long time and I helped him
with it and we just kind of you know
birthed it out of our friendship in the
in the contrast between our feelings
about you know meant the Manson Family
and also our own families and and you
know the difficulties in attractions
there in and once we sort of got linis
on board we decided to record a video
because we knew that we were going to
need all the help we could get
you